- - [Dhawal Sharma]
Good afternoon everyone,
and thanks for joining us for
this session, which is about,
what are the things that
we see at Zscaler with AI,
and what we've been doing with Zero Trust.
I also am fortunate to have
Matt Matthew with me, who is one
of our champions, who has drove some
of our technology at Amazon Robotics.
He'll talk about how they went about it.
So there's a lot of things that
I want to touch upon, cover.
We'll be around, happy to
answer any questions afterwards.
I thought instead of trying
to hit on one topic, I want to
focus on what's the bigger
picture that we are looking at,
key trends things.
So I'll try to hit on many of them,
but, if time permits,
we'll take some live
questions in the end as well.
So we are seeing a big shift
in the intelligent systems.
A lot of focus on automation.
You know, everyone talks
about APIs and automation,
and with agents,
and AI coming into the
picture that is becoming,
the race is becoming actually even worse.
Now, there were some
things that are lacking
and the adoption of agent frameworks.
Now, some of the things that
we are seeing around identity
and authorization for
agents, we are seeing
how the infrastructure
is readily available.
Some of those barriers are going away.
But if I take a step back,
you know, I've been at Zscaler
for close to 14 years now.
When we started the company
at that time, there was a big
focus on,
from CISO, we used to
hear, we never gonna take
our security to the cloud.
Security is meant to be
built into the data centers.
There are some mega waves that
come that provide tailwinds
to adoption of newer technologies.
It was internet, cloud, zero trust.
You know, it create new opportunities.
It changes the paradigms on
how we have seen a world
evolve over a period of time.
And it also needs a little
bit of mindset change on
practitioners like yourself.
But when we think about these waves,
there are some giga waves
that happen which
subsumed these mega waves.
It was industrial revolution
and we believe the big giga
wave we are seeing right now
is the AI revolution.
It started three years ago
when Chat GPT came out,
but that was tip of the iceberg.
There's a lot more
happening in this space.
Companies like us are also, you know,
we are evolving.
We are not just embedding,
we started with the focus
of embedding AI.
We, everything that we do as a company,
all of our products are becoming
more intelligent with AI.
But also how do we extend the platform
to secure AI for our customers?
So as we think about this
whole concept of trust, right?
We all built implicit trust
in networks to begin with.
I started my career building networks
and I know one of the thing
that we always did was,
we started by building trusted networks
and entrusted networks.
That's how firewalls
came into the picture.
But over a period of time, you know,
what we also realized is in
this world lateral movement,
you know, ransomware attacks, these happen
because the way we have built networks,
the attackers have
evolved to exploit that.
So the traditional security
models do not work anymore.
Like having, connecting
two sites with VPNs
and putting firewalls that
give you a false sense
of security doesn't work anymore.
Moreover, the new form
factors that are evolving,
whether it's AI agents
or IoT OT
traditionally we see
still people using a OT
IT separation firewall.
It doesn't really do anything
from a security perspective.
Just creates say demarcation point.
And then you think
about distributed system
that are always communicating
how do you secure that traffic?
So the goal is to make sure you
can adopt these technologies
to be more productive, but
with a secure framework.
We at Zscaler started with one
single vision 15 years ago.
I remember when we sat in
a room, we said basically
we will be a policy engine
or a switchboard between
traffic going from any source
of traffic to any destination.
Source, at the beginning was a user,
traffic was going to internet.
So we basically said what is the best
way to secure that traffic?
We built this highly scalable
distributed proxy in the cloud.
Then VPNs became a problem.
We build the zero trust architecture,
zero trust network access back in 2016
and now everyone talks about it.
So the intent is we all
have until then tried
to secure this communication using network
as a control channel.
Network is a way to connect things.
Network should not be the one
that on which the
security should be built.
IP addressing is a way to
label how traffic flows, not
how you secure things.
So that is the genesis
of how we have evolved.
Now, we everyone talks about
digital transformation.
We play a role in that.
The digital transformation
start with, you know,
customers transforming
their application lift
and shift to the application of the cloud
or building cloud native apps.
We partner with AWS,
and all of the hyper scalers
to make sure we provide fast connectivity
to these applications
running in public cloud.
But where we play a role is on the network
in the security transformation.
It started with the
security transformation,
network was plumbing,
everyone was using a
router-fi or a SD-WAN.
But now everyone is questioning
towards moving it towards a
zero trust based branch model.
Where the network is
just a way to connect.
It is easier to connect, you
can drop in a connection,
but it also has the concept
of zero trust built into it.
And I'll talk about that
in a minute as well.
But these are the two aspects
on which we play a role
and are able to extend our platform.
Now, when we think about zero trust,
we think about zero trust.
Everyone talked with ZTNA.
So ZTNA to us is not really
was a use case, right?
Zero trust network access is
users accessing applications.
Remote access without VPN,
that problem we have solved for many area.
In fact, one of the thing that we did,
especially after pandemic, you know,
everyone went to A-Z-T-N-A model
as employees started coming back to work,
we built this inside out zero trust model
with our customers.
Basically saying since users
are sitting in a corporate network,
I don't want to connect them
to application just because
they're on the network.
So inside out, zero trust evolve.
Then the concept of zero
trust everywhere evolve,
where we basically said, zero
trust is not just about users,
it's also about your third
party contractor, B2B users
or B2B sites.
We have like large
distribution companies who talk
to their supply chain
with site to site VPN.
Those companies don't have
a good security posture.
You can get your compromise through that.
So how do you make sure the zero trust get
extended for those use cases?
Then zero trust also gets extended
for workloads in the cloud.
One of the thing we have been
focusing very heavily in our
partnership with AWSs,
building a cloud native gateway service,
being able to secure all
the workloads ingressing
to the cloud without
deploying any firewalls.
So we have a very detailed
deep dive on this tomorrow.
If you're interested, you can
come back for that session
and then zero trust for physical sites.
And the new frontier that is
emerging is AI infrastructure.
Not just the Chat GPTs
or Gemini, the world that
you're using on your laptop,
but you think about agents
that you're gonna build
with agent core or foundational
model on Bedrock, right?
And they go across around the boundary
of a single hyper scaler to,
let's say, build with,
I was talking to someone at Agent Code,
they are also integrating with
the the models people can use
in Open AI for example.
So these boundaries will transient
and our goal is to secure
those communication as well.
But we are the switchboard policy engine
that sits in between.
So when we think about the transformation
that we typically see
in this architecture,
a lot of our customers come to us
from very traditional network
and firewall based architecture
where they back haul traffic,
they are connecting things,
bringing traffic to
certain traffic checkpoints
in their data centers
or in public cloud and then they're
establishing connectivity, right?
In this model there is network
complexity and cost involved.
There is a redundancy of security controls
and then there is also complexity
of managing that security stack.
Our goal is to shift customers
towards a simplified model
where we are the policy engine.
You bring traffic to us,
we give you form factors like
a client on the user desktop.
We have a physical appliance
that you can deploy at your site
or you could have a virtual
form factor in public cloud
where there's a lot of virtualization
to bring traffic to us.
Bring with the right user
context, workload context,
or with IoT device context
and build policies on it.
And do it in a way
that you are not doing
10 different policies
that don't understand each
other with a single context,
single policy that is tied into
your business requirements.
Now when we think about
zero trust for users,
there are a couple of things we do, right?
User could be coming from any device,
any location
or a guest wifi.
Could be a non-employee,
third party contractor,
when they're going to things
that are running on internet,
even SaaS applications like
Office 365, Google apps,
you don't run the namespace of that,
you don't manage them.
They are SaaS service, right?
So you wanna make sure that
you are securing all those
traffic flows,
and there are applications
that are managed by you,
whether they're running your data center
or they're running in AWS,
you own the namespace,
you own the DNS for them, right?
So your goal is to make
sure those applications are
not exposed on internet.
That is one of the foundational principle
where we say your IPs,
your namespace goes dark on the internet.
That is exactly what we're
private access service to,
but security should not come at expense
of the user experience.
So we, that's why we have
165 pops across the globe.
We can also extend our
footprint into a private
or hybrid deployment,
but things can go wrong not
because of where your
security is happening.
It can go wrong because
of end user device issues,
network ISP issues or
application performance.
So we measure that digital experience
and tell you where the problems are
and can offer you root
cause remediation for it.
But there as you adopt
new technology, you have
to retire your older technology.
Everyone's looking for cost savings.
So what we think of Zscaler,
like DMZ in the cloud,
we are subsuming the
functionality of a lot
of inbound outboard DMZs
that you have built,
a lot of traditional
networking you have built,
and replace that with the
zero trust architecture.
And as you think about,
how this,
stack is evolving,
one of the thing that I keep
hearing from customers is,
"I need to segment my network,
I need to segment my users,
I need to segment my applications".
We have built segmentation
as a foundational
policy construct in all of the products.
So you don't need a separate VLAN
or a IP network segmentation
tool, IP segmentation,
micro segmentation,
they all become complex.
They all are different rule sets.
They don't talk to each other.
I have worked with very large
banks with 300,000 users
and like 2,000 user
security engineering teams
that have struggled to deploy
micro segmentation product at scale.
Our goal is to make sure we
basically learn the behavior.
This is one area where we
basically introduce the concept
of intelligent segmentation or
AI in policies few years ago.
We basically understand who's going where.
Especially in your namespace
you could have a window server
running on under a rack for 10 years.
You don't know who's
accessing that, right?
You don't want to unplug it,
you don't want to block it
because you don't know what will break.
What we do is we basically
understand who goes where
and come up with a baseline policy
that we recommend and
you can implement it.
You immediately go from 0% segmentation
to 40,50% segmentation.
Now we are going deeper into it.
We what what we introduced
recently is we actually go
inside a department and
say these specific users go
to this application on port 4, 4, 3,
there are five app users in IT who go
to this application on a high port.
They probably are
maintaining this application.
You create a segmentation
policy for them on
that high port specifically
giving you more granular
identity specific segmentation,
and then you can push that
user group through skim
to your directory to basically
have fine grain segmentation.
We have customers who are
moving towards close to 80,
90% segmentation with this architecture.
So segmentation becomes a
practical deployment architecture
and not just a theoretical
concept with this.
So this is what we have
been doing really well.
I want to talk about what
we are gonna do in the cloud
and the AI space.
But before that, I would
like to invite Matthew
to join me here
to talk about the security transformation
at Amazon Robotics.
Matthew.
(audience clapping)
- It's for you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you Dhawal.
Good afternoon all.
My name is Matthew Foreman,
I'm a senior technical program
manager at Amazon Robotics.
I have the distinct pleasure
of serving alongside 150
of some of the most
skilled IT professionals
in the industry.
Today, happens to be my
3,852nd day one at Amazon.
(cameraman chuckling)
For those of you working
on doing that math,
carrying the one with
your fingers and toes,
it's about 10 and a half years,
that puts me in the top two
and a half percent globally
by tenure at Amazon.
Today, however,
is my first day one
presenting at AWS Reinvent.
So I'm not a betting man, which
makes me a pretty lame guy
that go out to Vegas after the conference.
But I promise you
that we're all gonna learn
something today, myself included.
At Amazon, one of our core philosophies is
that every day, is day one.
So what does that mean?
Our day one culture is not only a culture,
but it's also an operating model.
When we put the customers at
the center of everything we do,
we solve their problems.
When you combine that customer's obsession
with long-term thinking
and innovation, you start to understand
how Amazon approaches problems.
So who are our customers,
at Amazon Robotics?
We have about 5,000 Amazon associates
that our group covers across
nine distinct research
and development sites.
And that population has
collectively deployed over a million
robotic systems across
300 facilities worldwide.
As a business unit, Amazon robotics
has a goal to create a safe, efficient,
and sustainable workplace.
In the context of today's conversation,
safe includes information security.
Robotics IT is chartered
with providing differentiated
services to our customers.
Hardware engineers, electrical engineers,
software engineers, industrial
engineers, EHS engineers,
compliance, designers, lab technicians,
manufacturing technicians,
supply chain professionals,
strategy leaders,
learning and development,
security, facilities.
I'm probably getting very close
to naming my favorite child,
which is a proud father of one.
I haven't yet mastered that skill yet.
(cameraman chuckling)
What we're not responsible
for at Amazon Robotics IT,
enterprise wide services,
things like exchange,
Microsoft 365, unified
communication, printing,
standard non-specialized
productivity networks,
and builder tools.
So Amazon as a company,
began their zero trust
journey many years ago.
And I'm very happy to share,
that at the end of 2023,
almost two years ago exactly,
we completed phase one of
what we call our unfabric
program internally.
We externalized 454 sites,
facilities, excuse me,
and 158,000 applications.
Now when I say we, that's
really enterprise engineering,
not Robotics IT.
Like most programs however,
it's subject to the 80/20 rule.
You can have a world class
solution that solves 80%
of your problem, but
there's always a tail.
There's always something that doesn't fit
into your deployment model.
In our context, that's
legacy applications.
What do we call a legacy application?
A legacy application is one
that requires private
network access between users
and applications.
That application might be a
service, it might be a server,
it might be a file store,
it might be a SQL server.
Whatever it is, it expects
to live on the same private network.
Many of these applications
that we support in our business unit
are COS, commercial off
the shelf applications.
We don't have the ability to
modernize those applications.
We can ask nicely,
but ultimately we're
beholden to our vendors.
Some of these applications also use
natively insecure protocols.
Telnet, anyone?
So what do we do?
Well, we look at the portfolio.
I have a a subsection of the applications
that we use up on the screen behind me.
I'm gonna pause for just a moment
and allow everyone to
sort of skim through that.
I know it's a little bit of an eye chart.
So these tools generally fall into,
let's say three categories.
You will use these tools
in your environment,
which is what we do at Amazon Robotics.
You'll use tools similar to these,
to support staff,
or your teams.
That laundry list of engineering
disciplines, hardware,
electrical software, industrial,
EHS, compliance, design,
manufacturing, supply chain,
almost all of them use a tool
that is either on this screen
or in these product families.
And if, if you're thinking
to yourself, well Matthew,
I don't support any of these people.
I'm,
I really would rather
you just keep moving.
Every IT professional's
favorite peripheral,
printers,
I guarantee you,
I don't guarantee, in all
likelihood in your environment
somewhere there is a printer.
So Amazon Robotics took
on four tenants in our
zero trust journey.
We're gonna eliminate
the corporate network,
remove all dependencies on
active directory, no VPN.
Everything's gonna get moved
to the native AWS cloud.
Whether that's on-prem bare metal servers,
on-prem virtualized servers,
or existing EC2 resources
that are in the cloud,
but peered back to the corporate network.
We're gonna increase our security posture,
lease privilege access,
we're gonna automate user
provisioning and base lining
and we're gonna secure those applications
that use natively insecure protocols.
And finally, we're gonna
segment at every level.
So not only are we
segmenting our applications
like Dhawal was just speaking about,
but we're also segmenting
our infrastructure.
What does that mean?
Every single application
is its own AWS account.
There's no east west travel.
And we've implemented
least privilege from an
administration standpoint.
Someone who has access to the
console for one application,
doesn't have access to the
console for another application.
We reduce the blast radius.
So what is this shifting architecture
called within internally?
SAL, secure application link.
Anyone that works with me will tell ya
I'm a pretty plain English guy.
I like very simple naming conventions.
It started off as securely
link users to applications.
But SLUA doesn't quite roll off the tongue
as nicely as SAL does.
So in the SAL world,
we leverage zero,
the zero trust exchange as a switchboard.
Users connect to
applications, not networks.
And we do policy enforcement
in the zero trust exchange
for every single transaction.
ZPA, Zscaler Private Access,
enables us to provide segmented,
encrypted,
time bound,
lease privilege,
posture verified,
MFA compliant connections from users
to their applications.
Now if you're playing Info Sec bingo,
hopefully you just won.
So when we get into some of the specifics,
Amazon Robotics is a ZPA first customer.
It's something I'm proud to share,
because it's not your typical
Zscaler deployment model.
A lot of customers start with ZIA
or we'll do ZI, ZPA combine.
But as I mentioned,
Amazon Robotics provides
differentiated services.
ZIA wasn't in our portfolio.
It's not, it's not a
service that we needed
to offer our customers,
and the Zscaler team was
able to give us an avenue
to license what we needed
to to service our customers.
We integrate natively to our IDP.
We packaged our Zscaler
client connector client
to make it a one click install
with pre-configured
environmental variables.
These are all things that
Zscaler offers outta the box.
When you start to look
at the stencil diagrams,
we deploy app connectors in the AWS cloud.
They come very nicely packaged in AMIs
available on the AWS marketplace,
which means that Zscaler
takes on the burden
of much of the updates in the maintenance.
They're deployed in a
highly available fashion in
auto scaling groups across
multiple availability zones,
and application dependent multi-region.
Users can no longer directly
access their applications.
Applications require zero
inbound connectivity.
All connections are
inside out from the VPC.
ZPA enabled us at Amazon Robotics
to deliver a scalable solution,
which we call SAL across to all of Amazon.
Our day one culture encouraged us
to build highly effective
solutions for our engineers
and build long-term value for Amazon.
So today I'm proud to share
that we offer SAL as a service.
And depending on
how much time I can
negotiate from the SDEs
at our weekly standup,
it's either a white glove deployment,
or where we'll take on your
application and run it for you,
at Amazon Robotics.
We have a managed self-service model
where you can run your own app connectors
and we'll manage the exchange.
And then using Zscaler's
micro tenant capability,
we offer a fully delegated
administrative option
where partner teams
that are high on the maternity
curve can manage their own
solution within the architecture.
So, but wait, there's more.
I have a cool little device here.
This is the zero trust branch.
It's called a ZT 400,
Dhawal gonna talk a little bit about
zero trust branch further
in his presentation.
But we were able to take
all of the same primitives
that I just shared with
you about least privilege
application access,
and apply it to our physical world
using the zero trust branch.
We have on premise prototype labs
and manufacturing facilities
that leverage 3D printers,
CNC machines, additive,
subtractive, you name it, we got it.
Lots of cool stuff.
But almost all these devices
nowadays wanna be connected
to the internet and each
provider has their own SaaS
solution and you need to
worry about data management
and who has access to
your prototype files.
So by deploying zero trust
branch, we can operate all
of these devices in a
local network only zone,
but still gain all the benefits
of having them online available
through the switchboard,
that is the zero trust exchange.
This is another example of
how Zscaler helps us
obsess over our customers
and remove friction from their workflows.
I'm really proud to say that generally
when you add security, you add friction.
And I believe we've done the opposite.
We've increased security and
we've decreased friction.
So I've made a couple
claims today about how great
what we've done is and what
our customers think about us.
So I wanted to actually share
some voice of the customer
straight from our customers.
We solicit feedback from
our customers consistently
and more specifically quarterly.
One of my favorite bits of
feedback up on the top left here,
is that it works,
right away, 90% of the time.
Well, I'm not Pete DeSantis,
I don't run utility computing.
90%, probably is okay.
But I reached out to this user and I said,
"Hey, why, where's the 1%?,
What can we do better?".
He said,
"Well Matthew, if I don't
sign into Slack first
or access one of our
other corporate resources,
I need to do my MFA token every morning.".
(Matthew scoffs)
I said,
"Well that's not really a SAL problem.
We have some security
postures that require you
to authenticate every 18 hours
and if SAL's the first
time that you authenticate,
I'm sorry, you need to do your your MFA.".
But the feedback is positive!
Users perceive SAL, which
is Zscaler private access
is more performance than VPN.
And what they don't realize,
is it's because we provide
access to applications,
not networks.
When we get to the actual
numbers behind all of this,
since March we've migrated
49 internal applications
to the native AWS cloud,
using Zscaler private access.
Zscaler is available to 5,000
Amazon associates across the
Amazon robotics business unit,
and has over 700 daily users.
We've implemented least
privileged access to 100%
of those 49 applications.
And finally we were able to move all
of our COTS applications to the cloud.
We did all that while
deferring 75,000 VPN sessions.
So with that, I'll hand it back to Dhawal.
I know he has some interesting
things to say about some
of the AI works Zscaler been doing.
- Thank you Matthew.
This was great insight.
(audience clapping)
And I equally hate all the acronyms
that analysts throw at us.
Not a big fan of them, but
let's talk about zero trust
for cloud workloads.
We talked about zero trust for users,
cloud workloads, right?
This is a very interesting area.
We started dabbling in this
area about five, six years ago.
Our goal, which we have been able
to achieve now is securing
all workloads in all clouds.
Whether AWS or Azure
or GCP, you know, there is comp,
they're similar constructs,
but they're not exactly same.
So you have regions, availability zones,
you have different form of
connectivity from VPC peering
to direct connect that
you need to look at.
Then you have more persistent
workloads with EC twos
and then you have, you
know, your lambda functions,
which are non infrastructure workloads.
You need to secure all of that, right?
So broad positioning, as I said,
like three things we do here.
I have thousands of
customers doing what's the,
in the first bucket,
which is securing workload
to internet access.
This is where typically you
would deploy a north south
firewall or a virtual firewall,
but as I said, firewalls
are looking at sessions.
They're not decrypting traffic,
they're not actually doing
any real security other
than maintaining sessions.
And as you deploy more virtual firewalls,
it get more and more complex.
So I have very large
customers like United Airlines
who are doing petabyte scale egress,
without deploying any firewalls today.
Second use case is workload
to workload segmentation.
This gets interesting
because at a broader level,
workloads are like users.
They either are going to internet,
they're talking to each other,
but unlike users,
they don't have persistent identity.
So identity becomes challenging.
So we have been doing a lot of work
that I'll talk about in the use cases,
but the use case I, I typically see a lot
of customers jump into
micro segmentation trying
to segment at a workflow
or network flow level.
That becomes too complicated.
What some of our customers
who have gone on this journey
with us, what they did is
they basically zoomed out
and said we need to define
macro segmentation boundaries,
which is to say I have a VPC
that should is a pre-prod staging VPC
that should not be exposed anywhere
but to my production VPC,
it goes dark on internet for everything.
Or I have a specific
subnet in my data center
that is speaking to a
workload in the cloud
that subnet should not be
advertised anywhere else.
So those kind of macro
segmentation use cases.
And then you layer in micro segmentation,
epec-segmentation on top of it.
So our goal is to be able to do that
with a consistent policy framework,
as I mentioned earlier.
Let's look at how this looks like
from a multi-cloud security perspective.
First use case is, you know,
customers are shifting, lifting
and shifting applications to the cloud,
or they're migrating
applications to the cloud.
The use case here is a hybrid cloud
where you have a physical side
data center from the where
you are connecting to your applications.
We are able to basically
give you a very specific
policy to say a specific IP
subnet in your data center goes
to this VPC,
build the policy and build the access.
Then comes the second use
case, which is multi-cloud.
Some customers have multi-cloud
first versus their different
variance variations of it we see.
And the thing here is now we have been
integrated with AWS tags and
Macie tags for a long time.
Basically we con, we connect
via API to your tenant.
We consume those tags
and they become criteria in the policy.
You can say anything which is tagged.
SAP cannot talk to certain
applications for example.
So those tags in a way become
identity for your workloads.
We also read your VPC names.
They become, they become
locations in our console.
You can build policies around it.
There is also a lot of
in large scale customers,
we have seen complexity
around cross region,
multi-region deployments.
Multi-cloud is a reality.
We see customers, their
primary cloud is AWS,
but they acquire a small company
where they are running like a
Big Query in Google now,
they need to connect application to it.
So those scenarios come up
every single day in our world.
And then intra region, this
becomes really interesting.
Many of you who are from
a regulated industry like
healthcare or finance,
you need to have policies,
let's say PCI specific policies
at the workload level within
the workload that are
running inside your VPC.
So if even we have seen network flow base,
what is inbound versus outbound
so we can support those use cases as well.
So from a broader perspective,
we can give you a segmentation framework.
Full decryption, we don't even do,
you don't need to worry about just
doing domain based filtering,
which is what most
customers do with firewalls.
We can give you full SSL
decryption data security DLP on
your workloads, full sandbox
in advanced threat protection
for your workloads egressing through us.
And if traffic is going to stay
within the boundary of AWS,
we will not take your traffic outside AWS,
we actually extend our footprint in AWS.
Your policy enforcement
happens inside AWS as well.
When you think about now
specific rules such that you need
to build at a workload level.
So we introduced the micro
segmentation service,
but it is layered on top of
the ECL private access service
or the ZTNA service that
Matthew was talking about
because you guys are already
doing app segmentation with us.
Micro segmentation layers on top it
as a specialized use case,
you don't need to rebuild
that from scratch.
So you get full visibility
of network flows,
what is going in and
out of your workflows.
We can, we can support
containers and EVPF for example.
We can support network flows
and build policies on it.
We can give you process level visibility
and then layer in the
intelligent segmentation
that I talked about, not
just for user to app,
we are extending it for app to app,
or workload, workload to workload as well.
On top of it,
one of the friction point,
the point of insertion
for Zscaler is,
we have a service called cloud connector,
which is a VM built as
with full, you know,
Terraform cloud formation support,
auto scaling support could be deployed,
with full automation,
but you have to manage
a VM for that right?
To egress traffic to us.
A lot of customer deploy
them in landing zones,
they deploy them in their security VPCs
with a gateway load balancer.
So there's a lot of reference
architectures we support
for that and it can scale
for terabyte scale traffic.
But some customers came to us saying,
while we need that, for some of our,
to remove the friction
for our developers to
make this as part of their
shift left practices,
what if we don't need to deploy any VM?
So this is where we
introduce the cloud gateway.
It's, it is generally available in AWS,
we just launched it in GCP as well.
So here you don't need to
deploy the cloud connectors
or any virtual infrastructure
using your managed
endpoints in AWS.
You can point traffic to us.
Think of Zscaler running a VPC,
like how we run a Zscaler
cloud in our data centers,
and in AWS.
We actually have a full
VPC in which we will set
up these cloud connectors
with the auto scale function for you.
You don't need to deploy anything.
And the one big thing it does
is it basically removes your
friction from deployment.
I have customers who actually
are telling their developers,
you can set up your VPCs
without any firewalls
and no upfront audit,
just follow this reference
architecture and they get audited later.
But this deployment
takes 10 to 15 minutes.
I have customers like
Siemens who have deployed,
who our developers can deploy
their workloads without going
through weeks of approval cycles
with this reference architecture now.
So, when you, we talked about cloud
and Matthew touched upon
the branch appliance.
He showed you the smallest box
that we introduced two three years ago.
ZT 400 that supports up to 200,
300 megs built for smaller sites.
We have been supporting
multiple hardware sizes.
There are one new rack appliances
that support one gig egress.
In fact, we just in September
introduced our campus
appliance, which is five gig egress
and 40 gig within the
branch for east-west.
The concept of zero trust branch
is not to build an SD-WAN.
You know, about six years ago,
seven years ago when every
security company was building
or buying an SD-WAN, a
lot of customers came
to us saying why is
Zscaler is not doing it.
I fundamentally think that the concept
of SD-WAN was required at that time
because it gave a smarter
router with more automation.
We opened our connectivity APIs to connect
with every single SD-WAN vendor.
We support automation
with about two dozen SD-WAN vendors today.
I think now only six or
seven of them are left,
but we basically have
automation with them.
But SD-WAN has a big fundamental flaw
that it basically creates
very permissive network connectivity
and it creates side to side connectivity.
It creates more mesh
networks which actually
increases the attack vector.
So one of the thing that we
wanted to do was we took time
to build the right architecture of
what we are calling a zero trust branch.
Many of you probably follow Gartner.
So Gartner has started talking
about zero trust branch
architecture as a few months ago.
We've been talking to them
about this concept for a while.
But this cafe like branch
or Starbucks like branch model is simply
that you have a hardware
appliance that you can plug
and play,
bring two ISP circuits,
and it subsumes the functionality
of your SD-WAN north,
south, and east west firewall.
Your NAC layer three switch.
What do you need in your
branch? In this case you need
a gateway appliance that we provide.
You need wifi access point,
you need L two switches
to connect more things to the port.
You don't need anything else.
Now, you need routing.
We support full routing protocols on this,
but you don't need to do over permissive
routing or firewall rules.
For example, in this
case the inbound like,
Matthew again talked of printing.
Printing is a something that
I see a lot of manufacturers,
there's remote printing use
case SAP printing for example.
Typically you will poke
holes in your firewalls
to allow inbound access.
The same firewall ports
rules are exploited
during ransomware attacks
and your network gets locked.
We basically build the ZPA
logic, the app connector,
the gateway that we have with ZPA,
containerized on this hardware appliance.
Which means the inbound access is driven
with a identity based policy,
not with a routing protocol.
We support O-S-P-F-B-G-P everything.
But most of the complexity
that we created ourself over the years,
and again I have done a lot of networking,
a lot of that is not required.
We can simplify that and
that's something that a lot
of customers, when you bring security
and networking teams to sit together,
they appreciate the value.
It also simplifies your M and A.
A lot of customers of us
grow with acquisitions.
You want to connect to networks.
That is a wrong thing to do
because you're gonna bring the
security posture of a company
with a poor security
posture to your network
and that can cause issues.
So one of the big value
proposition is not connecting
network, not worrying
about overlapping IPs,
and connecting application to
application or user to users.
And if you're in manufacturing,
one of the big use case,
we acquired a company called
Air Gap Networks last year,
which was very focused on OT security.
So we subsumed that as that
in the zero trust branch.
So it basically becomes a DCP
gateway gives the slash 32 IP
to every device on the network
and air gaps every device.
So it create micro fences every network.
So it is micro segmentation
without any agent.
So your cameras, your shop floor devices,
your IOTs are also fully secured.
Like in Zscaler corporate
network, we are not huge,
but our corporate network in San Jose,
has close to a thousand employees.
We have multiple engineering labs.
We don't have a corporate network anymore.
I connect to a guest network
when I go to our office.
When I connect to the
engineering labs on the set
on a different floor,
I'm going through the policy engine,
and these appliances are protecting us.
We don't have SD-WAN or
firewalls anymore either.
So we have good reference
architecture we can share with you.
But the intent is this
progression going from users
to branch, to cloud.
You are able to secure it everywhere.
And also the goal is that,
a lot of of of platform
generates a lot of telemetry.
So one thing we have been
doing from day one is,
all our telemetry could
be fully integrated
with any SIMs you're using,
any security operation,
data lakes you're using, we
should support SSF framework.
We actually integrate with
the AWS data lakes as well.
So our customers are able
to get very verbose logs
which are kind of goldmine
for security operations team
and they can actually build lot of
rich data pipelines from it.
And also our products are very, a lot
of you think about Zscaler
as a cloud security company,
but we have deployments
that are a hundred percent on premise.
We have deployment in like,
like classified networks,
which are air gapped and not
even connected to networks.
So we can support pure SaaS
based cloud-based model,
hybrid model on-premise model.
There's a lot of flexibility on that.
But core intent is to get
better security and simplify
and also reduce your costs.
The last thing that I want
to cover in my session
is about AI.
This is top of mind for
everyone I'm talking to
and even my partnership partners.
When I look at it with AWS in
the last few weeks I've been
spending a lot of team that are
building the AI infrastructure.
We are getting deeply embedded
and having those conversations with them.
But as I said, like it, everything
started three years ago.
I remember we were at the
RSA conference in April,
Chat GPT came out with
GPT three, 2.5 model
and everything changed after that.
Now there are thousands
of gen AI applications in enterprise.
One thing that everyone
is trying to figure out is
what gen app people are using.
So this is where in last
two years we have classified about
2,000 different applications.
We have prompt extraction
and classification for
dozens of application
and you can do your
traditional DLP on them.
You can get full visibility into
what is going on in this prompt.
But where a lot of
interesting work is happening,
as I mentioned, is around agents.
So AI started with predictive AI.
We are in the generative AI cycle.
Everyone is talking agent,
but agent is more marketing so far,
it's,
I haven't seen a customer
who has deployed a lot of agents at scale.
Some of financial services I
talk to, they are experimenting
with embedded agents in their chat bots to
basically converse with consumers.
But they're not settling
insurance claims through that agent.
I think that world is gonna go there
in the next 12 to 18 months.
But are we ready to secure that?
On top of it, agent themselves
have multiple types.
In my view in next, few,
quarters at least,
most of the agent traffic
will come from agents embedded
inside SaaS application.
Your Salesforce will
have a Dreamforce agent
that will be agent,
and when I say agentic,
it's not just web traffic,
it could be web socket,
proto buff protocols.
It could be a two A protocols
and I recently,
I follow a lot of ITF forums.
I saw eight two A protocols,
which were with Linux Foundation
have actually gone to ITF forums now,
which means they will get standardized
and will get used more and more.
There is a lot of focus on agent identity.
A lot of startups,
Microsoft introduced their Entra ID.
I've been working with the AWS IM team,
which is also building more
IM capabilities in this area.
So we integrate and consume
identity from everywhere.
But the interactive agents is
something we are seeing more.
Chat bots for employees
for, you know, consumers.
Autonomous agents is
very, very early stage
and they are digital
colleagues, digital twins,
which are going to have same
permission model, r-back model
that you have as user,
but they're your digital twin.
When we think about securing
AI, we have two parts to it.
One, something we have been
doing for two plus years.
Again, thousands of customers
securing public gen AI
applications and being able to secure
that traffic extract prompts
and then being able
to run AI guardrails on
that traffic as well.
AI guardrails are more sophisticated,
small and large language
model based detectors,
that find things that typically
your DLP engines cannot.
And specific tools also build like a lot
of customers are using Microsoft copilot.
So we can actually have
copilot readiness to tell you
what data it is touching
in your environment.
But what we are doing on the right side
is very exciting area.
Which is to secure AI infrastructure
and AI application that you're building.
So here we are,
we introduced what we call
as AI guard, which is runtime
guardrails for AI systems,
which basically sit is
a LLM proxy that sits
between your LLMs,
and your application that
are conversing with LLMs,
or users who are conversing with LLMs.
These are, again, small
language based detectors.
We have built this on AWS here.
You can basically say if you use Bedrock
or Agent Core, you can
actually invoke them on day one
and your application to LLM request
and the response for your
LLM all is inspected here.
We have out of the box
support for Bedrock,
Anthropic, Open AI,
and you can also do it with
any other system as well.
But when I look at broad AI
security equation, right?
There are four big pieces,
we are looking at it.
We have, we introduced AI guard in June.
About dozens of customers are in deploited
in early access VR.
We are doing gio-card in January, 2026.
But it is something that a lot
of customers have interest.
But we also realize AI
is such a new area that
that traditional direct teaming
tools don't work in this world.
There was a huge gap in this market.
So, this is where we acquired a company.
Two weeks ago we announced,
we acquired SPLX,
which is AI soft bill of material,
AI asset management and
direct teaming company.
And there's a lot
of governance framework
we are able to build.
So we already provide this
level of visibility for a couple
of years where you have the
full visibility of shadow AI,
you have visibility of
what AI usage by department
and you can build policies,
can do prompt extraction.
Now with the acquisition of SPLX,
we can actually give you
full visibility into your AI
infrastructure and apps.
So we can see what models
are being deployed in your
environment, what MCP servers are used.
We can give you full
visibility of your agents
and your models, talking
to your git repositories
and what is going on in that workflow
and full visibility of what
guardrails are deployed.
In fact, one of the thing
that we just rolled out,
we have ability to read
guardrails on Bedrock
and we can say if you have enabled them,
and find vulnerabilities
through rec teaming and fix them as well.
Also getting the full
visibility of the infrastructure
and tying that into data.
Like say with our data protection we
actually classify your data.
We actually see where that data is sitting
and then tying that AI
footprint to your data as well.
So looking at infrastructure,
looking at data
and tying it together as
well, which is very unique.
What SPLX brought specifically
to the table is being able
to scan your entire AI
infrastructure, your AI projects.
You can run scanners either
through a SaaS service we run
from AWS, you can deploy it is
as a multi-tenant, single tenant service.
You can also deploy it in
your data center in a private
deployment if you need that.
But there are a lot of adversarial attacks
that have been pre-populated.
You can simulate them.
Typically when you are
building AI projects
you run these scans,
you fix things
and you run a scan again before
you push it to production.
But AI world is very dynamic.
If a new GPT model
comes, you basically want
to redo these scans.
So that's something we
support out of the box.
We have support for, for
example, Gemini four,
when it came within two days, right?
So you want to be ahead of that.
I talked about guardrails earlier.
There are multiple guardrails we support.
Every bullet item here
is basically a small
or a large language model
that is understanding your agentic traffic
or your LLM traffic and
learning the output.
If you're a car manufacturing company,
it basically says that
the consumer who's talking
to your LLM is not talking
about another car competitor
and trying to get a quote from you.
If your insurance company, it'll do that.
So there's a lot of that
readiness built into it.
But also learning is in involved here.
And governance is important,
one thing that we have been
doing is there are new AI
frameworks coming, EU AI, a lot
of European customers
have been asking for it.
So we have reporting on it.
NIST, AI risk management
framework and OS AI top 10.
We have a lot of analytics
that maps the vulnerabilities
and risks that we find to these as well.
So as I mentioned,
our goal is that what we have been doing
for many, many years in zero trust world,
marrying that into the AI..
We are one of the richest
source of security logs.
We have introduced certain capabilities
around asset management
and you know, agent security operations
that I won't spend too much time.
But that's an area that we
are evolving ourself into.
We have one of the, a very
exciting product deployed
with about 5,000 plus customers,
which we call a ZDX or
Zscaler digital experience,
which is built from day one
with AI to fix issues
that end users are facing.
We can find root cause
or bad user experience,
remove that time spent
on solving user tickets
through a deeper integration
of tools like Service Now workflow tools
and being able to automate remediation.
So network operations,
IT operations service desk
uses it very, very heavily.
But at the bottom is what
you see is AI data fabric.
So we have a,
we acquired a company called
Avalara two years ago,
which basically is a general
purpose security data fabric
that connects to 150 different
kinds of security products,
networking products
and subsumes their logs
and can correlate contextualize
those logs to say out of
50 different or 10 different sources,
I'm seeing indication of log four J coming
from 10 different products,
and this is what I can tell
you is the problem here.
And then you can map it to assets
and try to fix those problems.
One last very important topic
before I wrap up my presentation is,
people ask us,
and this is a question everyone ask,
all of their vendors these days,
"Is Zscaler using my data
to train the AI models?",
The answer is "no".
There is a a QR code.
We actually have a detailed document
and a blog on this that you can read.
We do not use customer data for it.
We have a lot of training data.
If we are gonna use your
data to train in context
of your training,
we basically strip out all PII from it.
So your data is safe.
We are not a end,
point application like
Salesforce or Office 365.
We don't use to user data on it,
but we do have metadata,
like when we store a transaction log,
we know which user it is for,
what location they're coming from,
but we can strip out all that information
and we use that intelligence
then to power your tenants,
your information on that.
So as I wrap up my
presentation, three big things.
We've been talking about it,
secure, simplify, transform.
You can't do that one at a time.
You need to have a good digital
transformation strategy.
And our goal is that we
come in with the intent
of securing your data,
securing your applications,
your workloads, simplifying
your architecture.
We come, we see very convoluted
network architectures,
whether it's in branch or cloud.
How do we simplify, have
more consistent policies
and give you more agility to
move faster as a business with
by taking out a lot of
complexity from your networks.
With that, we'll wrap up the presentation.